all right we're gonna talk about some
solid kick-ass hurry but first gonna
think the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by Harry's
Harry's is a personal care brand
reinventing the way you shave he said
with his apocalypse beard and hair you
got apocalypse beard - I know you so
guys shave the other bits though I mean
on the Perry's delivered straight to
your door you don't have to wait in line
at the grocery store convenience store
sit back relax play for your razors and
Harry's guarantees a close comfortable
shave with a 100% money back guarantee
and the deal Harry's has for you is you
click the link below go to harrys.com
slash Jeremy John's us right John's with
a knight spelled a little differently
than it sounds to some papal Harry's
we'll send you everything you need for a
close comfortable shave for just 3 bucks
weighted handle with texture grip a 5
blade razor cartridge perfectly balanced
does all things should be foaming shave
gel and a travel cover to protect your
blades when you're on the move and they
donate to good causes giving 1% of their
proceeds to organizations that promote
better mental health I appreciate that
so click the link below join the 10
million people who have already tried
harry's and thank you very much to
Harry's for sponsoring this video I do
appreciate it right now we're gonna talk
about some fighting that's really
undercutting it
[Music]
the raid 2 so the raid 2 is the sequel
to the raid once again directed by
Gareth Evans in the raid two events have
happened that forced our protagonist
Rama to have to infiltrate the criminal
world that basically runs everything so
now he goes deep undercover and those
are your cliff notes for the plot
there's actually a lot that happens in
the raid 2 I'll give it that so like a
proper sequel the raid 2 doesn't give
you just more of what was in the first
one they've expands on the characters
expands on the universe I mean not the
universe on a cosmic level but you know
the universe the world of the movie now
we have a deeper story with Rama the
world is more fleshed out and it reminds
me of John wick which I have a tendency
to say the movie I'm talking about is
like another movie which makes people
think I'm saying John wick came out
first or in the case of my review for
the first raid Dredd I know the raid
came out before Dredd glad we could
clear that up also the first time I saw
The Prestige was not one week ago it was
back in O seven glad to clear that up
too like there's a little
miscommunication my fault I'm sure sway
it is the way I talk but it does make me
think of John wick in the sense that
John wick had this pure simple story for
the first movie and then John wick 2 & 3
is like alright now we're gonna deep
dive we're gonna find out the meat and
buzz we're gonna go into the bone marrow
of what makes this world work and that's
what the raid 2 does objectively
everything in the raid 2 is stepped up I
thought the acting was really good the
action top-notch the first raid had that
camera work that cinematography that I
just a gush over and it has it in the
raid to also screw falls out of a door
and it's all in slo-mo and then it hits
the ground and then boom the action
starts but the camera definitely does
look cleaner in the raid 2 is compared
to the raid 1 maybe it was just Gareth
Evans having more experience by the time
he did the raid 2 maybe they use better
cameras I don't know all I'm saying is
technologically speaking the raid 2 just
looked superior to the raid 1 and the
fights - I got you over some nice bloody
violence I just do Thank You ed boon
Thank You Mortal Kombat for making me
that way but this movie has the
hard-hitting fights the insane
choreography I mean the nasty hits that
people take you like the raid 1 you'll
love what happens in the raid - I heard
that kitchen fight was amazing it was
and in the subway my god when it started
I just I heard the words of a great man
stop have time and
boy was it however for me in the raid
movies nothing beats neon bulb sticking
out of an AK well dudes fighting two
people I'm just saying that's that's
pretty crazy that's my personal favorite
that's kind of that's what I'm gonna
think about with the raid 1 in the raid
2 though the raid 2 stepped it up on any
level I can really think of everything
from the fights and storytelling the
thing the raid one has at the raid 2
just can't really have the simplicity of
the first raid movies kind of what makes
it so beautiful and so rewatchable we
got bad guy he's in his bad guy tower
alright good guys going there it all
gets locked down now good guys got a
fight bad guys the problem is the first
raid movie is so pure and so watchable
Dredd was like sounds good does in that
I feel like the raid one has better
pacing when we're talking about momentum
I mean if someone had to have done this
by now right has anyone clocked how many
fights there are how much screen time
there is with the fights and the raid 1
vs. the raid 2 because if you do that I
feel like the raid 2 probably has more
fights whether it be a fistfight going
toe-to-toe or just a slaughter
murder well where's the raid has more
fight so it also has longer stretches of
no fighting and that's all in the name
of character development and fleshing
out the story which is good and as we're
gonna run into objective versus
subjective what do I prefer versus what
is objectively better like the raid 1
versus the right 2 is kind of like when
people have the great argument of well
what's better Arkham Asylum or Arkham
City I prefer Arkham City is one of the
best comic book videogames out there
ever but there is an argument to be made
of the fact that Arkham Asylum has that
tight claustrophobic feeling that you
can only get from Arkham Asylum that
Arkham City just can't have and that's
what I feel like the raid 1 has for me
over the raid 2 doesn't change the fact
that the raid movies they're great I'm
glad I own them now the raid was taken
and now for the sequel you have this two
and a half hour long Odyssey essentially
and although the raid 1 is my preferred
rewatchable slaughterfest the raid 2 is
a proper sequel as a sequel should be
it'll actually give you a lot more depth
than you thought you were in for if
you're just going on the first raid
movie the raid 2 was worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray maybe I can get
the John wick going right here good lots
of guns
it's a neo lion but he also said it as
John wick so account and
curious is your perspective so the raid
- have you seen it what do you think
about it and what do you prefer the raid
1 or the raid 2 I feel like that is
gonna be the conversation here I can't
emphasize enough how rewatchable the
raid 1 is for me I might actually watch
it tonight well I can't watch it tonight
I have to edit this video so tomorrow
but whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]